بينما الحديث غالبا ما يدور عن العزوبيه
بين الشباب وصعوبات الزواج يبدو ان كثيرا
من الشباب والشابات في الواقع لا يريدون
اي مكان للعلاقات الحميميه في حياتهم فما
القصه
صادمه اكدت ان جيل الالفيه الموجودين قبل
العامل 2000 يختارون بشكل متزايد ان يعيش
من دون علاقات حميمه وبالتاكيد يتساءل بعض
ليس من المفترض ان تصل الرغبه في هذا
النوع من العلاقات في هذه المرحله الشابه
من العمر
[موسيقى]
الدراسه وجدت ان الموجودين بين عامي 29
2011 و
1996 اختاروا بدء العام 2023 بالتزام
الامتناع عن العلاقات اما بشكل دائم او
لفتره وجيزه
وعندما سئل هؤلاء عن السبب لاسيما ان
الكثير منهم اتخذوا القرار مع ازواجهم
قالوا انهم يريدون تطوير حب الذات
والاحترام والاستقلال اضافه الى اكتساب
فهم افضل العلاقه مع الاخر
خبراء في الدراسه يشورون الى امكانيه وجود
فوائد كبيره لفترات الامتناع عن العلاقه
الحميمه بين الازواج خاصه اذا كان الثنائي
يعاني من مشكله في التواصل
الدراسه وجدت ان الابتعاد عن العلاقه
الحميمه على الاقل فتره قصيره يمنح
الاشخاص فرصه تكوين روابط اعماق تتجاوز
الرغبه لان الهدف في نهايه المطاف هو
تنميه الحب وتنميه الذات
ووصلت جاذبيه الموضوع الى حد جعل الكثير
من المشاهير يتحدثون بصراحه عن تجربهم مع
هذا الخيار على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]